>> YOU KNOW WHAT PROBABLY ISN'T A GREAT
WAY TO GET VOTERS ON YOUR SIDE?
DINE AT YOUR PRIVATE CLUB WITH
WHITE SUPREMACIST AND HOLOCAUST
DENIERS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
LAST WEEK.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD WHITE
NATIONALIST AND HOLOCAUST DENIER
NICK FUENTES, RAPPER KANYE WEST
NOW KNOWN AS YE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT CLAIMED
FUENTES WAS AN UNEXPECTED GUEST
AND HE KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT IT.
HERE IS WHAT CHRIS CHRISTIE,
POTENTIAL RIVAL FOR 2024, TOLD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER SKPAM OF
AWFUL LACK OF JUDGMENT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHICH MAKE HIM
AN UNTENABLE GENERAL ELECTION
CANDIDATE FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN 2024.
MARC SHORT, DO YOU AGREE?
>> I DO AGREE.
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE JUDGMENT.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR IT.
I THINK BACKSTAGE HILARY
REMINDED ME THAT MAR-A-LAGO WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST CLUBS DOWN
THERE TO ACTUALLY ALLOW JEWS IN.
THE REALITY IS, I THINK WE ALL
KNOW HIS AFFECTION FOR HIS
DAUGHTER IVANKA WHO CONVERTED TO
JUDAISM.
IT'S INCREDIBLE POOR JUDGMENT.
SINCE THE ELECTION IN 2020, THE
PRESIDENT HAS DESCENDED DEEPER
INTO THE HEART OF DARKNESS.
IT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY I THINK
REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION IN 2024.
>> I MEAN, I'M NOT SURPRISE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
CHARLOTTESVILLE AND YOU HAD
PEOPLE MARCHING DOWN THE STREET
SAYING THAT JEWS WILL NOT
REPLACE US, AND THEN YOU HAD THE
PRESIDENT SAY THERE ARE GOOD
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
WELL, WHY WOULD WE BE SURPRISED
THAT HE HAD AN ANTI-SEMITE GO
DOWN AND HAVE DINNER WITH HIM,
EVEN IF HE DIDN'T KNOW, OR
ENTERTAIN SOME OF THESE
CHARACTERS?
DONALD TRUMP IS HOMOPHOBIC, HE
IS AN ANTI-SEMITE, HE DOES
RACIST THINGS.
IF HE IS THE CANDIDATE FOR 2024,
I THINK IT WILL JUST NOT BE BAD
FOR REPUBLICANS, IT WILL BE BAD
FOR OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE IT WILL
CONTINUE TO POLARIZE US AND
CAUSE THIS HEIGHTENED Z TENSION
OF HATE AND VIOLENCE IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT PEOPLE ARE SICK OF.
I THINK IT WAS ECONOMY, BUT I
THINK IT WAS THAT, TOO, THAT
VOTERS ARE TIRED OF THIS ANGER
AND THIS VITRIOL THAT IS COMING
FROM OUR ELECTED LEADERS.
>> AND YET, KRISTEN, YOU KNOW
THE REPUBLICAN ELECTORATE FROM
POLLING IT.
IS IT TOO SOON TO SAY EVEN WITH
THIS DINNER, EVEN WITH JANUARY
6th, EVEN WITH, EVEN WITH, EVEN
WITH, THAT DRAM IS NOT VIABLE
FOR THE
WONDERING IS THIS GOING TO BE
THE THING?
IS THIS THE THING WHERE HE
CROSSES THE LINE, AND FINALLY
EVERYBODY DECIDES NO, LET'S TURN
THE PAGE.
I THINK WHAT MAY BE DIFFERENT
THIS TIME IS REPUBLICANS ARE
WOUNDED COMING OUT OF THIS
MIDTERM.
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE TAKEN
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE BY A SLIM
MARGIN AND ARE LOOKING AROUND
SAYING SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO TURN THE PAGE, CHANGE
SOMETHING.
WHETHER THAT IS JUST A FEELING
OF REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON OR
HAS IT BLED OUT YET INTO SORT OF
REPUBLICANS, YOUR VOTERS,
PRIMARY VOTERS?
I THINK REMAINS TO BE SEEN, BUT
I KNOW THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE
DONALD TRUMP SEEMS WEAKENED,
SEEM MORE VULNERABLE.
AND SOMETHING LIKE THIS, MAYBE
THIS TIME AROUND IT FINALLY DOES
STICK.
>> 15 SECONDS.
>> I'LL TELL YOU WHAT HASN'T
CHANGED.
WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT HIM.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE WANTS.
WHAT WOULD CHANGE THIS DYNAMIC
IS IF WE ALL STOPPED TALKING
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
THERE IS THIS ACTUAL
CONVERSATION IF I WERE A
REPUBLICAN, I WOULD WANT TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT DOES
ABORTION MEAN FOR US GOING
FORWARD, WHAT IS THE HOUSE GOING
TO DO, WHAT ARE THE POLICY
ISSUES FOR THE FUTURE?
BUT NOBODY IS DOING THAT.
WE IN THE MEDIA KEEP DOING THIS,
TOO, WE KEEP GIVING DONALD TRUMP
OXYGEN.
>> WHEN SOMEBODY IS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS DINNER WITH AN
ANTISEMT AND A HOLOCAUST DENIER
AND HAS NOT CONDEMNED IT, IT'S
WORTH TALKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.